[Music]  anyone with a blue suitcase  you may now board finally no not you sir  not me this is a blue suitcase I read on  the internet that it's not against the  law for me to go to the bathroom while  the fasten seat belt sign is on so see  but is it against the law though the  light is on because a good law you see  that there's a picture of a seatbelt on  that side okay I just I just wanted some  leg room okay max legroom you get yours  meanwhile I'm gonna go Haven pant in the  airy awesome Terri's especially when  they get froggy maybe maybe  you have to have the canopy the puppy is  what they were going to have okay oh  don't they serve that in the cafe across  the street our soup today is the boat  lamb assault with the just a dash of  shittim vodka and served with melted  pistol Tasha back with you hello Greece  where the yogurt flows like water mmm  yes like go good but to stay  [Music]